Welcome everybody to another zoom call and cover up that came in remember to send your questions in on the form on the member site.
Remember to do that otherwise you can just chat them in through the chat during the call.
All right remember to look at your members home page especially for any updates.
So we've had numerous updates with the right.
True right is having trouble with the 634 software.
We're recommending currently that you don't upgrade to 6.4 right now.
I have numerous videos on how to do it if you do and you're ready to find all the 6.4 well then just stay with it.
So, but I will go over that I went over this last week and it's right on the site so I'll let you guys look at that.
All right question what is your opinion about your therapy urine therapy in my case it is applied urine to an open cancerous tumor.
Well urine therapy has been around for a long time controversial like so many things are the idea is that your own urine contains healing benefits and healing nutrients that can help heal wounds.
There's even been urine therapy where you drink your urine urine it does sound very gross but your urine should not have bacteria or in it so it's not like it's you know.
But it contaminates your body unless you have a UTI and some sort of bladder infection you should not have any bacteria or viruses or pathogens in your urine you don't expel those through your urine.
So, but I don't have a strong opinion about it because I have not had anybody over the years that has done it.
That is really giving me any feedback so I don't know honestly I don't know if that would be beneficial or not.
I don't think it would be harmful so there's a different person I will send you my labs when I get them all back but two weeks ago my hemoglobin was up to 9.3.
However hemoglobin should be over 12 usually but you don't really get concerned telling gets down into the 8th or the 7th and today it's down to 8th so of course you know low hemoglobin is probably your best indicator of fatigue so hemoglobin is a part of anemia.
So in different types of anemia you'll have low hemoglobin low red blood cells low B12 there's all there's different types of anemia but the anemia that you get with cancer is called the is called anemia of chronic disease that's actually the name of it.
But with cancer it has to do with multiple things but one of them is that cancer can be gobbled up here iron and causing anemia cancer can be causing leading causing anemia cancer can.
The cancer there is like chemotherapy and radiation can cause so the rest of this person's question i'm still taking the supplements you could be on but would radiation knock it down is there anything else I could be doing so this person just had radiation and yes radiation is a major cause of anemia.
So an radiation can knock that down now once you're done with radiation your body will build that back up usually so you don't really need.
But there are some things you can do to help pull the radiation out of your body and there's some further questions about some patch on those in just a second.
But also let's move on have lots of edema in my legs hands which started on the right side but now has moved to the left side.
I have started occupational therapy to wear wraps and exercises is there anything else I can do i have also done some little panic massage and some brushing.
So I have several blog posts about edema and swelling and how to help move that one of your body.
Remember that your lymphatic system does not have a heart it works totally by action of the muscles so you need to be moving your muscles you know so if you have edema in your hands you need to be doing some hand exercises some arm exercises.
Anything that's going to contract the muscles is going to help to move fluid out of the tissues so I would work heavily on that massage deep tissue massage on your hands and legs can be helpful as well.
They're stroking towards your heart they're going to be moving fluid through the lymphatic vessels through the romantic vessels there's there's typically a valve at the maximum forage as a part so as you move fluid through that there's a check valve that it won't go back or so as you get things moving that's going to be the most helpful.
So what's the cause of the edema so edema can be caused from blockage physical blockage because the person had lymph nodes removed that's the most common that we talk about here because the person might have had surgery and they had lymph nodes removed so that they have less active flow edge sites for the edema to exit.
Edema can be caused from medications that's probably the number one cause of edema is different medications that a person has been on.
Edema can be caused from chemo and radiation as well so just working through those things so you're doing somebody's right things I would say look at the as far as other things that you that is possible is.
The swelling program the inflammation program on the right and make sure you're doing your iron pro wave programs that can help with detoxing that as well.
I have lots of edema both hands and legs actually in my torso also not sure if this is anything to do with the hemoglobin or not no typically the edema doesn't have anything with the hemoglobin.
So two separate shoes.
Can radiation cause edema yes and no so radiation can damage blood vessels radiation can cause leakage because it is a toxin can cause leaky vessels.
So you can get more edema from that that's and especially if you have a sighties in the torso you think that can be tied to that not tied to the the little human.
What be 12 supplement do you recommend that is not methylated with regards to methylation please explain the concerns with cancer in this case now touch can slow both.
So the concerns with using a lot of methyl groups is that methyl groups what they do in our body is they turn off genes so what a person is has been termed there's been terms that have been out there since.
genetic testing came out that people can be under methylated or over methylated don't really use that terminology so much because you're not really an under methylated or over methylated depends on what you're consuming and and you know what you're being exposed to in your diet as far as number of methyl groups.
A lot of times when people initially did people's genetics they found that the gene the empty HFR gene is there's two genes in that family and the 1298 and the 677 genes the empty HFR genes.
Those were the first genes that had some research on them and that showed that when you have defects on those genes you don't methylate through the maternity cycle as well so then a lot of nutrition has started giving people five tetrahedral folate methyl groups in supplementation
and that ended up causing a real problem because it's more complicated than that when you give too many methyl groups it affects downstream different things it can methyl groups turn off different genes and it can activate different pathways by turning off different genes what they found with using too many methyl groups by practitioners that didn't take them.
The big and a picture of a person's health is that it caused a lot of emotional issues because if a person also has defects in another pathway called the biopteran pathway you end up producing excess serotonin and excess serotonin could cause rage issues and anger issues and it actually a person could become dangerous.
You know that with excess serotonin so using methyl groups in supplementation you have to be careful because you have to look at downstream pathways as well.
If you have COMTG defects if you have defects on the serotonin genes and you are using methylated 12 you can cause a lot of emotional upset even OCD issues anxiety issues so you have to be careful with methyl groups that way.
But with cancer I take a little bit different approach to this because excess methyl groups will turn off genes and look at the genes that we're trying to stimulate through using like curcumid and other anti-inflammatories that are getting rid of NFCAPA beta precursors which are inflammatory precursors we're trying to clear the way so that certain genes
especially what are called the tumor suppressor genes are able to turn on and that's what helps stimulate apoptosis of cancer cells or cancer cell death.
Though if a person with cancer is taking a methylated supplement they have to be careful with it and only take that for a period of time for a very specific purpose.
I just talked to somebody on the phone today that I would say they should take a methylated supplement for a period of time for the specific purpose because their homocysteine levels are too high.
So homocysteine is the final downstream piece of the methylated pathway and if the homocysteine levels are too high then you should add some methyl groups for a short period of time a couple weeks and test the homocysteine test again and you test homocysteine through complete metabolic profile.
So should a cancer patient with normal homocysteine take methylated folate or methylated B12?
I say no because you don't want to turn off tumor suppressor genes.
Access metal groups will turn off tumor suppressor genes but I said they'll do far worse than that.
Access metal groups will cause issues with the biopter and pathway cause emotional issues cause anxiety issues and that is often, you know, the reason why a person may have emotional issues.
I've talked to people over the years where they were giving their child methylated supplements and they couldn't figure out why Johnny had so much rage and so much anger and he was labeled now 8080 HD.
He wouldn't listen in class and it all had to do with this methylated folate that the mother was thinking that she was doing him a favor by giving it to him.
But all of a sudden you take that away from him and all of a sudden all his emotional issues calm down.
So you can do harm with different supplements so you have to be careful with that.
That's the long answer to that.
We typically recommend B12 in the form of pro hydroxyl cabolamine.
So there's three forms, well there's actually four forms of B12 out there.
That's a molecule which is the most commonly used and I think it is one of the most commonly misused supplements.
That's a methyl group.
So cabolamine is B12 it's either tied to a hydroxyl molecule it's either tied to a denticel molecule or it's tied to a cyanom molecule or it's tied to a methyl molecule.
So that's the answer patients take methyl cabolamine.
I don't recommend anybody take methyl cabolamine unless they have looked at their biopter in pathway also from a genetic standpoint and they monitor symptoms from an emotional standpoint.
But cancer patients I recommend either a denticel cabolamine or hydroxyl cabolamine.
This company PHP professional health products or methyl genetic nutrition makes both the pro hydroxyl cabolamine.
Either one of them are good supplements either one of them work just as well both of them are lost and just and that's the way to take your B12.
Can you take too much B12 in the form of pro hydroxyl cabolamine or pro adenosyl cabolamine and the answer is really known.
It's a water soluble supplement that's not going to stay in your system.
And it will circulate in your blood and it's not uncommon for a person to do a blood test and show elevated B12 levels.
And then thinking that or their medical doctor who's not knowledgeable in understanding that will say, oh, you're going to get off your B12 your B12 levels are too high.
Your blood B12 levels being too high causes no issues whatsoever that effect many times blood levels of B12 too high tells us that the person isn't getting B12 into the tissues and they need to keep B12 at that high level because they may not be getting them into the tissues.
People with elevated blood B12 and they're not even taking any B12 that really tells you that they're not getting B12 into the tissues and that can be a B12 anemia.
So you have to be still taking B12 even though your blood levels are high so that's a common misconception of reading blood work.
Roxychomolamine or adenosylchomolamine is just fine.
Supplements with the fourth type of chomolamine or B12 the cyanochomolamine should be avoided completely.
I am totally not a fan of acylchomolamine.
It is a synthetic and I think more toxic type of chomolamine.
Is it common to experience more pain from a tumor when exposed to the right overnight frequencies?
Are there any answers? Yes, that is common.
Do look at our blog posts too. We have a blog post on good pain, bad pain.
And I have, you know, some things written about what I wrote, but there's a video on that blog post called good pain, bad pain.
Watch that video that will help you discern, you know, what is going on and what is normal, what isn't normal.
We have written supplements to take along with full fox chemo.
We have read that Burberry and Artemisident have synergistic effects.
We are also planning to do IV vitamin C and ALA pre and post chemo.
All of those things are good.
The only thing that I would be careful of with the full fox chemo is an IV chemo is to follow the chemo protocol that's on our blog post again.
We look up chemo protocols and a good pain, bad pain.
And you'll see about doing a fast before chemo stayed off of your, your anti oxidant type nutrition for the 48 hours.
You can do that always with a IV chemo doing a fast prior to it and state of anti oxidative supplements for 48 hours.
So that the chemo will work better.
Burberry and Artemisident aren't typically classified as antioxidants.
They will help synergistically work with any chemo really any of your immune supplements are going to help with chemo synergistically working better because it just helps your immune system attack chemo same thing with.
Not just with chemo, but with the needle therapy. So over the six years since my diagnosis I have seen very slow things happen in my breast.
I was perfect after a year of all nutritional healing.
And then things begin to feel as if bad things were happening. Now it seems they see nothing of significance in it yet it is hard feels like calcified in most of the bottom half this person is talking about a breast tumor.
What would this be from well, you want to look at some scans to know exactly what it's from.
Many times a tumor will will wall itself off and will become hard inside and yes even pick up minerals and calcium because it is dead tissue so that is a good thing.
And I've shared the story before about a patient I had a number of years ago that had lung cancer and multiple tumors in their lung in their surgeon was was.
Begging them and begging them and really becoming very pushy about surgically removing those tumors and finally the person came to removing the tumors and the doctor said these are his words the surgeon's words it broke up like a puff ball.
And it was all dead cells in the tumor and he wished he wouldn't have got the surgery because the surgery was supposed to take X amount of hours and it took three or four or five times that long because the tumors just literally broke apart and he had to clean out all of the tissue.
And yes, that's the goal of natural care is it necessarily I know it's everybody's goal for the tumor to disappear and it's not there and they say they're cured.
But really the goal is for it to stop growing because by definition it's not acting like cancer anymore is not replicating so many times your body doesn't know what to do with that best and it will just wall it off.
So it can become calcified the real concern is that larger has it gotten larger is it getting larger is it metastasizing the only way you're going to know that by is by getting further scans.
The recent lesions found in my liver and many small tumors in my spine and pelvic doctor not concerned much about the small ones yet I get severe pain with being on my feet too much as in normal day activity what do you recommend for pain what does no damage to the liver or stomach.
Well, whatever you have pain you always want to find out why so whatever you have a symptom you don't just want to find out how you can take the symptom and make it go away you want to find out why the symptoms are there so if the pain in your.
I beat on your feet too much is in normal day activity is from the tumor if it's from a tumor or a test is in your spine you want to address that so you don't want to magically even if you could make that pain go away because then you wouldn't be getting the signal that something you roll.
So you do want to address that if you have metastasis of the spine and it is causing pain, you do want to address that and that's where I would suggest that radiation might be an option if that's what they've talked to you about and it might be a good option because what you could do spot radiation on a bone many times you could kill the cancer that's in that bone.
Not a big fan of radiation to soft tissue but radiation to bone could be really lifesaving in a lot of different ways.
I did not see recommended protocols in the members area for radiation treatment where there is daily oral chemo pill a days of radiation treatment which is five days a week.
So if you're doing an oral chemo pill you really can't do the chemo protocol so the chemo protocol that we write about in the blog post is really for an IV drip of chemo for you know that takes place over a period of a couple hours and then you're going home and now you're staying away from.
You know you know antioxidants that we discuss in that and we discussed multiple times and now you can go back on that so typically I recommend if you're on a daily chemo pill even if it's just five days a week for the period of radiation or the daily chemo pill that many breast cancer patients go on that they're on you know for years sometimes that you don't change your your protocol as far as.
nutrition goes you're still staying on antioxidants you're still staying on your other nutrition if you're if you're doing IV vitamin C you're doing anything else you don't really change that you might not do IV vitamin C that you know during the five days of radiation but you certainly go back to that to help pull that out of your body and that's another thing about this question here about what do you do to pull radiation out of your body.
Well, using all your key lady type nutrition is going to be the best thing as far as a radiation protocol radiation treatment and help pull radiation out of your body.
follow up the next question before to these are two holiopaths that we have we have our holiopath that can help pull radiation out of the body in this radio that radio religion radiology which can help pull radiation out of the body to.
These are just different holiopaths now in truth nothing is going to work perfectly our key later is going to pull radiation out of the body somewhat nothing is going to be perfect for radiation.
You know that's the dangerous effects of radiation on our body they just it just can stay in our system like for you ever so whereas chemo is a chemical that chemistry you know you can key late that and theoretically pull that out of your body radiation affects tissue and damages tissue that it is more long lasting and you have more long lasting.
It will affect possibly too so the more things that you could do to heal the better so last week when asked you recommended to continuing IV vitamin C during radio chemotherapy but when would you do IV vitamin C infusion so that the vitamin C does not neutralize the effects of the days of treatment.
So I would you know if if the chemo pill you're only doing it for those five days of radiation I would wait until after the radiation to do it I be infusion can you do like a zomal vitamin C during that time well I get there there's different theories about this some practitioners will say absolutely you should be doing it every day that'll help protect your healthy cells.
I mean the radiation it it's hard to argue with that that that being a strong possibility but you want that radiation to work as best as possible so it was me I'd probably wait even with the light was oval vitamin C until after I was done with those five days it's not like 30 days that you're you're waiting on this if I was doing a 30 day session of radiation which isn't uncommon with a lot of people with cancer.
And then I would probably stay on the lapel zomal vitamin C but for five days I think I would go off of it and then maybe wait another day or so afterwards and then go back on it.
I just finished 10 radiation non irradiation questions here treatments I was doing high dose vitamin C and was feeling worse after my IV so this is a different person stuff say personally ask that last question.
And then the call you mentioned to take a break which I have yes so is there anything else I could do to help get the radiation out of my body so these things any of your teenagers any binders the clear binder any other binders that you're taking all those things will help.
Again, nothing's going to be perfect to pull radiation on your body but binders, key laders, homeopaths, antioxidants, glutathione, vitamin C, all those things are going to be the best thing to pull radiation on.
When we spoke earlier today you said to take zinc and vitamin C to help reduce my high copper levels do I take them at the same time or do I take one person the other later no I said those in your package today.
So you don't need to order my through bottles of both those in there that got shipped out with that ball today so you don't have to worry about ordering them take them at the same time.
So take the zinc and a teaspoon of the I gave you the life was almost vitamin C and the bottle of clear zinc I would do three a day.
The zinc and the vitamin C do watch like I said so a person that has copper toxicity which a lot of people do very comfortable person has copper toxicity if you start taking zinc because that's what you would help that's what you take to pull the copper out of your body.
You could actually feel sick because zinc will grab copper out of the tissues but it ends up dump it into the blood and you could end up with technically like a herxide or type reaction so you can feel ill you can feel like fluids you can feel sluggish you can get headaches.
But if you take the vitamin C with the zinc and it can be just a squirmic acid that you have at home but I had some like was able vitamin C so I gave it to this person which is even better but taking vitamin C with the zinc helps grab on to the copper helps it pull pull it out of the mind.
So I'm not a fan of using copper and supplements there are whole food supplements that have copper that's naturally occurred there's no getting around that.
But any supplements that add copper to them.
Especially in doses that exceed the daily limit of copper you're getting copper and your vegetables is out like we don't need copper it's just that we get too much copper and even copper that we're exposed to as a child let's say you lived in a house that had copper pipes which like probably 60 70% of the homes in America have copper cloney.
A lot of people use copper cookware a lot of people have used those copper bands copper does absorb through the skin.
It's was very popular you know a couple years back to use copper for people who have arthritis it's really helpful no it's not excess copper is really dangerous so and copper for cancer is even worse because copper helps stimulate growth and we don't want that but excess copper.
Whether a cancer not can lead to what's called copper toxicity and can push out the sick levels and you really need to stimulate it to be a response to help kills cancer.
After my best activities I've been working with a physical therapist to prevent lymphedema no problems with that but I am getting corny which feels like chords that run for my underarms to my mid upper arm.
The PT's are working with me but can't explain why this happens do you know and is there anything else I can do what's a matter of just doing everything possible to help move the lip corded occurs when you have blockage because can almost always occurs when you've had blockage because you have removed lymph nodes or close surgery.
So just keep working on that these will go away adema settles in your tissues and in the fashion layer as well just keep working on you've got to be patient with it too don't try to push it too hard and you can irritate things too when you're if you're doing heavy.
Detitial massage or something you can actually be irritating the tissues and causing more adema so you're going to go gentle with them.
I'm getting ready to do the mycotox lab as instructed for three days I'm avoiding taking my glutathione and all cell core supplements because they have binders in them anything else.
Common to avoid is an ac okay or avoid that to I avoid the anac to anacinocysthy reason why you take it is because it's a precursor to glutathione it helps stimulate glutathione recycling so I would stop back to.
I'm extremely low on B12 and I am anemic still but improving slowly so I should not be taking.
A B12 metal cobalty but instead hydroxyl quality.
Yes that's my opinion you should be taking hydroxyl cobalty that metal cobalty the only people I think.
That have cancer that should be taking metal cobalty is if you also have high homocysteine so if you have elevated homocysteine levels then you need to take metal cobalty.
It doesn't actually actually have to be metal cobalty it can be metal cobalty too.
But my cysteine levels are normal okay so then go on a hydroxyl cobalty or the adenosium cobalty either one you might have them in your in your you know covered but either one of those you should also use a loss edge.
Because B12 is difficult to absorb for a lot of people through the gut lighting and a person can be taking plenty of B12 in whatever form but they have a peritious in either I mean they don't make the enzyme for the pathway to absorb it through the gut wall so that's why you take a loss edge and you.
Refrain from sucking at it too quickly because you wanted to absorb through the buckle you close up of the cheeks not through swallowing you know just suck it on the loss edge and swallowing the deliciousness of the tasty loss edge because you wanted to absorb in your mouth but not in the gut so be careful of that anybody that's taking the beach one.
This is a very bad batch of Chinese herbs caused my intestines to feel raw and caused diarrhea to this person is taking Chinese herbs from a different practitioner because I was so depleted I didn't IV right in and see with methylated bees with a glutathyl push now I feel this was a mistake I have flu symptoms low fever and spasering my neck any suggestions on how to feel better.
So let's talk a little bit about the methylated bees that you would get in an IV so really all so typically if you're going to get B vitamins in an IV they're going to be synthetic they're not going to be whole food vitamins so I'm not in favor of getting taking B vitamins in an IV at all unless the person's got is so damaged I can't absorb bees and you have to do it that way.
I do you know doing methylated bees on one instance like an IV of methylated bees isn't going to be a mistake so that in itself just because they were methylated doing it one time don't consider that a mistake I just don't want you taking methylated bees on a you know supplement on a daily basis when you're a whole cystitis which is not going to be the same.
It's when you're a whole cystitis which is normal limits because you can be causing those other things that we talked about earlier.
I have flu symptoms low fever and spasering my neck I don't I don't very much it's from that one instance methylated bees and I don't that it's from the glutathyl though I know the person asking this question is very sensitive.
Very sensitive to different supplements and when you're doing IVs of any supplements you're taking fairly high doses so you're really flushing your system so the fact that that took place could be an issue so the other so a lot of people will ask can I do a glutathyle with my IV vitamin C because the practitioner that I'm going to let's do an IV vitamin C she said we could do these other things in the IV to of course they're selling bags of this stuff right.
Well is a bag of glutathyl beneficial um well the answer is yes and no it so when you're using glutathyl so go back to the seven phases of detoxification thought process detoxification is like a river so if there's a blockage anywhere or let's say not just not a blockage but there's an impingement somewhere.
In through that river and you start pouring more water into that river ups back upstream then you're going to cause a flooding downstream and that's where that's what maybe is what you're experiencing.
Glutathyle functions really on the phase zero level because glutathyle yes it does support phase two pathways in the liver because glutathyle does function there but glutathyle's primary function is really intracellular meaning in all your cells it helps.
It's so important that way it is your main intracellular antioxidant but it also will if you have a lot of toxins in cells it can dump toxins if you have take excess glutathyle it can dump toxins into the blood and it can overwhelm if you if your phase one pathway is a little restricted you can have excess toxins flowing through your blood stream.
Try to get out through phase one of the liver and phase one of the livers like hey dude we have a waiting list you have to keep circulating at least toxins at the circulate again coming back to the liver again hey can I get in now no no I told you to take a number and they have to circulate again that's what makes you sick so when you use key layers.
When you use key layers in excess when you shouldn't be using too many key layers I see this often where people are like I did a test with my practitioner it said I had mercury toxicity he put me an EDTA and TMS oh and this DMSA and this this key later to pull out this mercury because I got to get this out of my body and I felt sick after was it's because of this reason why I'm saying so.
The only thing you do is support the liver support these pathways make sure that you're having good moments do coffee animals if you possibly can if you can't make sure you don't cast oil packs over your liver make sure you're doing hot packs at least over your liver make sure you're using diners to grab onto stuff so that that's not the pitch in that you're absorbing this stuff and drink a lot of water just kind of flush.
And you should be fine but got a still sensitive that is dealing with this new batch of Chinese herbs that's caused your intestines to be an issue I've said that's why I don't use Chinese herbs because you just I just don't trust the suppliers and there's too many contaminated stuff coming out of China to be honest.
So using some things just to call me your stomach is going to be your best thing call me your gut stone.
Has anyone ever mentioned any external hemorrhoid issues with doing the coffee animals I do them daily for the last two and a half years love them developed when I think some mother some hemorrhoid.
I know anything's possible just the irritation of the tube could cause issues I haven't heard of cause a hemorrhoid.
I do have blog posts on hemorrhoids and things that you could try to do on a film.
I don't remember the nutrition of the time from my head.
Radio chemotherapy is five days a week for five days with the chemo killing.
I stopped your leave invited to see expert who actually answers emails.
If I should continue reordering, I invited to see critical which I've been doing for six weeks now goals every for 12 weeks is answer was I wouldn't change anything.
Yeah, so there's a lot of people are like continue to do that.
So there are papers that seem to support this as well. I would agree.
Is there a lot of an AC and clear talks.
I'd have to look at the ingredients again.
It doesn't say but it is listed first.
Just I would just go off of it for three days and that's going to be a bother to go off for three days just so you get a clean reading.
I had implants put in on Friday.
Recovery is going well so far. That's good, good, good surgeon said it was very high risk for reoccurrence because I didn't do chemo radiation to oxygen.
So doctors don't use scare tactics at all, do they?
Noted but I'm still going to pursue naturally any input for anything new. I should do now for recovery going forward.
Also is it true that it will take about a year for the swelling for the surgery to go away?
Well, I do think everybody's different with that. So they probably say that so that they get less people complaining.
But no, I don't think it's going to be a year with sweat.
So especially when you're doing other things to help with that.
Getting a lot of comments from from our case reviews that I live with just the high pressure that, you know, colleges are using on people to get them to do.
They're procedures. It's just, it's just, to me, it's just highly unethical.
Are you familiar with the books practice of the emotional code and the body code.
I've not read the books but have a Christian friend who does it for me and others. I have other Christians brand who has rejected it recently due to the concerns of your evil spiritual activity.
I do not think the emotional code and the body code is involved in any evil spiritual activity.
I think they're just by there, just using different acupuncture points and different things that can help stimulate your body.
They may use new age, you know, words in that like chakras and different things like that.
But I don't think you practice eating it as you pray over the practice of it.
You're doing anything wrong from a spiritual perspective.
And others different Christians out there that just literally throw everything out.
I used to have a pastor once that said, you shouldn't be doing acupuncture because that is, you know, anti Christian.
And I said, you know, to it's far more anti Christian for you to go to a Chinese restaurant run by a Buddhist, you know, non Christian.
That it is for you to go to an acupuncturist that who's a Christian, an acupuncture is not a spiritual technique whatsoever.
It never was it is not practiced that way in China or any other country as a spiritual technique where you could argue that yoga is a spiritual technique.
You can't argue that with acupuncture with acupuncture points because it isn't.
And so I wouldn't be concerned with any evil spiritual activity that's involved with emotional code.
You know, you know, you know, practicing Christian, so, I mean, if you use wisdom, whatever you do, are you familiar with the moto water and paper remedy putting water over written words and using the water for healing.
Yes, I am there's a book written about it. I can't remember the name of the author, but your words are powerful. You could actually find many.
Biblical verses that tell you how powerful your words are, then you shouldn't be speaking negative things over yourself.
That's something I have to catch myself all the time because I tend to use derogatory humor about myself, because I deal with stress with humor, not very funny.
But it's humor and see there again, but speaking negative things over yourself are very is very is very damaging.
You have to speak positive things over yourself. Paul is ordering us in Philippians chapter 4 to say to talk about if there's anything pure anything lovely, anything holy, anything worth complimenting worth thinking about worth being positive about focus on those things.
That's what we're supposed to put our focus on. He's speaking to a church that's being persecuted by the robots. So, just because we're going through tough things, we can't be thinking of how tough are what we're dealing with is we have to go, hey, God's got a purpose for this in me and praise God.
I'm still alive today. Hey, God, you can promise that we're going to be alive tomorrow. You know, so we need to be thankful for every single day above ground and know that God's got a purpose for me today. How am I fulfilling that purpose? How am I bringing him glory today?
It's certainly not why I needed crab meat about, you know, how I feel or, you know, how sick I am. And so we got to be careful of that. We have to guard ourselves for that. And you, you should put people around you. This is my opinion. You should put people around you who love you enough.
To, to reveal you, I heard sharpens, I heard the Bible says, meaning that you need to have somebody around you that's willing to slap you in the face when you're not acting God and your conduct is not glorifying God.
We have no right. I don't care how sick we are or how, you know, difficult our life is is to be victims. No, where does it say that you have a right to be a victim in scripture and believe me, they're, you know, we live in a time where we are in the richest country in the world, we have the most comfortable country ever to live on this planet.
And we live in homes that are ancestors with only dream of that are that kings and palaces of old work as nice as $150,000 suburban to bedroom, Randall are today. So we have nothing to grab about it. We need to have people in our life that will hold us accountable to us, not allowing ourselves to be a victim.
I think I wrote some blog posts that talk about how you can't afford to allow yourself to have those negative thoughts.
So, you know, I'm not a believer in positive thinking Christianity, but I am a believer that negative thinking Christianity doesn't want no good. So there's truth to our attitude is so, so important.
I have a bladder infection. You recommend crayons. I'm three to six a day. I'm concerned about possible lower immunity.
And that it could go to my kidneys, but I do not want to do antibiotics. I read your blogs about UTIs and doing probiotic confused yogurt, rectally, vaginally.
Are there more supplements or practices that could be healing you start this one thing at a time, definitely.
And most bladder infections are viral. They're not bacterial. So most bladder infections, most UTIs don't do well with standard antibiotics anyhow. So good. Continue with the coffee and it was this one.
Okay, with that, we will bid a due for the night. Know that I'm praying for all of you and keep up the good work. Keep focusing on healing. Keep a good attitude. And like Paul says, if there's anything good focus on that and understand your purpose is to bring God glory. It's not to heal. It's not to, you know, have joy. It's not to anything. It's to bring God glory.
It will better how difficult our circumstances are. All right. Bye bye everybody.